right-hander brandon woodruff yeah
woodruff with that 2.08 during drunk
average that's good for
ninth in the national league key right
here is be ready you get you get one in
your spot you go ahead and let it rip
winker with two aboard and two down one
ball two strikes to jesse winker
slider and a ground ball to left field
against the shift a base hit
rounding third and scoring is
castellanos and jesse waker continues to
swing a red-hot back big two-out
two-strike hit grazie r.a
0.96 that's sixth best in major league
baseball yes 28 strikeouts that's third
and his three wins are tied for the
major league lead one ball and two
strikes to garcia
got him swinging on a fastball to win
the inning
so unlike woodruff gray able to slam the
door after some early wildness
the 2-2 pitch swing and a miss struck
him out fastball at the top of the zone
smoke swings through it and sonny gray
has back-to-back punch-outs kemp
pitching this at bat
through a fastball right down the middle
go fig when all else fails holt had to
be guessing all the battling he had
going on and added bat on breaking balls
2-2 to castiano's
and that one's in there called strike
three it's another one partner right
down the middle yeah 97 miles an hour
and that's in there called strike three
woodruff with a strikeout his first
three up three down inning two k's in
the inning for brandon he's got four now
yelich in his career against sonny gray
is two for six hero with a decent lead
one pitch to christian swinging a rocket
down the right field line fair
casting here is going to have an
opportunity as it rattles around in the
corner eddie cedar is going to send him
home yelich is on his way to third
here's the relay home not in time it's a
run scoring triple by christian yelich
and we're tied 1-1
a missile right past the glove of joey
votto
and as that ball got caught up into the
corner castellanos had no choice
and no chance to try and get hira
scored with relative ease
winker singled home nick castiano's for
the reds only run today it was his fifth
hit in aided bats against brandon
woodruff in a 1-1 pitch winker swings
and sucks this one to right center field
that's it a ton way back there it is
gone jesse winker puts the reds back on
top 2-1
it's winker's first home run of the year
and rbi number three
well you gotta love that
winker's been swinging the bat much
better as of late and he is now eight
for his last 19.
castellanos rolls over one fair ball
tough play long throw
and it's in time for the out nice play
brock holt wow
grabbed it
all in one motion able to get it off the
first base not able to get much on the
throw but got rid of it quickly and got
the out down with the sign
suitor here it is swinging a smash
towards right
diving grabbed by casting huron he
throws him out nice play
took a base it away from winker
nice diving grab by
casting hiro
almost squirted out of his glove but he
hung on and threw him out big spot for
manny pina one out second and third two
one reds
one and one
on the ground and through for a base hit
smoke is in
matthias to third as manny pina delivers
the game tying
it's an rbi for pina all tied at two in
the six david bell is out of the third
base dugout to go get a starter sunny
gray pitching change being made for the
reds
ray's day is done no margin for air for
lorenzen here as he inherits runners
base is loaded only one out
lorenzon here it is casting hero lines a
base hit to left
one run is in they'll
hold the runners at first second and
third
casting hero
solid base hit to left
matthias is in
they are still loaded
all count one out lorenzen deals and
it's ball four
another run will score as yelts draws
the walk and rbi the easy way
not so easy that was pretty close pitch
so three and one now
and there's ball four so morrison draws
the wall for the bases loaded
the merry-go-round continues
it's five to two now
david bell will take the ball from
michael lorenzon
and
a move that
does not work at all did not retire a
batter they're still loaded up for smoke
swinging a liner into left that's in the
gap two more runs are gonna score
justin smoke
has been up twice in the inning he's got
a double and now a single driving in a
pair
hit that one right on the button casting
here had a key hit last inning two hits
today and a line out
and that ball's into center field
jankowski on the run he's at the track
and it is gone
up and out of here kesten hira
his third home run of the season bernie
will hit the slide
and the brewers add to their lead it is
now eight to two yeah you know they say
when he hits him they stay hit i mean he
just has that sound to it
eight runs on nine hits now yelich into
center field that one is way back and
gonna fly oh my goodness hits the
scoreboard
christian yelich
bangs one off the miller light sign
an absolute rocket
about to be outdone by casting here he
hits one even further
up off the miller light sign out there
in center field wow
bases loaded
ground ball to third jerko goes the easy
way and that's it the brewers win
their first home win of the year
and the brewers go to six and seven